meanwhile shares of energy companies
plunge today after the conservative
suggested a plan to cap energy bills
would be included in their election
manifesto centrica the owner of british
gas or its shares fall by three and a
half percent while shares of sse felt by
nearly two percent those two companies
were two out of only three fallers on
the footsie 100 today Lawrence ladies
chief executive of energy UK which
represents the country's energy supply
so Lawrence the case that conservatives
are making for this they say in the
market isn't working for too many people
in particular for poorer households yeah
i think that the point we're trying to
get over is that actually there's a heck
of a lot of work that's already been
done in his plan to be done that is
really changing the shape of this market
50-plus electricity and gas suppliers in
the market now over five million
households changing supplier last year
so this is actually a market that's
changing dynamically and I think what
I'm really worried about is really well
intentioned intervention canít tree have
we have unintended consequences and I
think things like this have to be really
fought through particularly in the
market where as I say things are
changing so fast I mean seven out of ten
households are still on the standard
variable tariffs which are the ones that
the tour is want to cap they often don't
provide the best value for customers do
they sometimes i do sometimes it don't I
mean it depends on your circumstances
really but that number is also dropping
so every year and the last numbers out
to march 2016 for example nearly a
million families came off standard
variable tariffs and I think there are
better ways that the Conservatives or
any other government for that matter
could look at how you can really make
sure and reach out and get people
engaging in this market but the Tories
clearly believed that with seven out of
ten households still on this tariffs the
energy suppliers aren't doing enough to
encourage customers to shop around I
mean why we come in it with insurance
policies for example when you renew you
get a thing saying you know shop around
on the only on your letter from the
insurer as you do in the many occasions
with with the energy secretary but
you're right to say that more needs to
be done obviously it does and i think
that the point I'm trying to get across
though is that there is this commitment
to actually doing more there is a
recognition that we need to do more that
we need to reach
and in particular we need to reach out
to those people who aren't confident in
actually entering and engaging the
market that's why the industry has
recently launched a switch guarantee for
example to help give people that bit
more confidence when they're entering
the market so women bed Miliband
announced a very similar-looking policy
in 2013 the tourists said this was 70
stylesight controls and a gimmick
dangerous do you go along with those
sort of adjectives here well I think I
fall back and really what what my Wayne
worry here is around unintended
consequences that we've seen lots of
interventions in the energy sector and
they haven't always worked out in the
best interest of the consumer and I
think at the heart of the discussion
that I want to have with any government
whoever comes in on the night for you is
how do we work together to really
deliver a market that works for everyone
that works for those people who already
engaged but how do we pull into the
market those people who aren't on the
best deal how do we get them onto the
best deal not just for a year but for
years to come it's just going to put
some supplies out of business do you
think I think it's going to put a lot of
people under pressure I think as I said
you know we've got 50 suppliers plus in
the market now I want to keep a vibrant
dynamic market and I think the way to do
that is working together government
industry and regulator to get that
market singing for all people